it is my pleasure and honor
to host you in Israel
your visit reflects the powerful bones
and friendship between the United States
and Israel
the Strategic relation between our
countries and the Deep defense ties
under your leadership
our cooperation has reached New Heights
two recent examples include the
transition of the IDF to centcom and the
excellent joint exercise juniperock
these bonds
is critical to Regional stability
and the security of the state of Israel
this includes above all ensuring
Israel's military superiority in the
region
today
we find ourselves at a critical point in
time
in the coming period
we will need to make
pressing and important decisions
Iran aims
to gain nuclear weapons and threatened
not only Israel but the entire world
Mr secretary
it is our duty to take all measures
necessary
to prevent Iran from Gaining nuclear
weapon
in this matter our capabilities
and our cooperation
have great meaning and Power
we dedicate a great part of our meeting
today
to discussing areas of Defense
cooperation
the Iranian nuclear threat requires us
to be prepared
for every cause of action
I repeat and emphasize
we must be prepared
for every cause of action
should Iran again
nuclear weapons and the power of nuclear
deterrence
the Ayatollah regime will only increase
its activities
supporting Hezbollah and Hamas terrorism
and exporting Advanced weapons around
the world including uavs and accurate
missiles
we will see terrorism against innocent
across the region including the people
of Iran
who suffer under a violent and open
oppressive regime
Mr secretary
as the son of Holocaust Survivors
I'm fully aware of the heavy mission
that rests on my shoulders on our
shoulders
we must do everything in our power to
ensure that the dreams of the ayatollahs
are never fulfilled at any cost
as for the Palestinian Arena the state
of Israel seeks stability and security
we are interested in the economic
prosperity and the well-being of the
Palestinian people in Judah in Somalia
and in Gaza
this should never come at the expense of
the life of a single citizen of Israel
and in face of terrorism we will be
determined per size and Powerful
secretary Austin
allow me
on this occasion to express my sincere
appreciation
on behalf of Israel Defense
establishment
for you unshakable and personal
commitment
to the ties between our countries
and to the security of the state of
Israel I look forward to continue
working closely with you
today we show our friends and our
enemies
that from the youngest soldiers
to the highest leadership Israel and the
United States stand shoulder to shoulder
thank you very much
Please Mr secretary
well good afternoon everyone it is
terrific to be back in Israel
and Minister Gallant thanks for a very
productive meeting
you know we've already spoken several
times by phone but
it's great to be here and to be able to
sit down in person with you and your
team
and I wanted to be here to make
something very clear
America's commitment to Israel's
security
is Ironclad
and it's going to stay that way
as president President Biden said on his
visit to Israel last year
the connection between the Israeli
people and the American people
is bone deep
Israel is a major strategic partner for
the United States
in that very special relationship began
when President Truman
became the first world leader to
recognize the state of Israel
11 minutes after it was formed
and that was some 75 years ago
and our bond is rooted in far more than
just shared interests
it's rooted in the shared values of
democracy and freedom
and the rule of law
and those values remain essential
as President Biden has said the genius
of democracy of American democracy
and Israeli democracy
is that they are both built on strong
institutions
on checks and balances
and on an independent judiciary
and the President also noted that
building consensus for fundamental
changes
is really important to ensure that the
people buy into them so
they can be sustained
now for generations and across
governments the United States and Israel
have worked together to strengthen our
ties
you can see the depth of our commitment
to Israel's security
in the robust assistance that the United
States provides to Israel
our historic memorandum of understanding
with Israel provides 3.3 billion dollars
annually
for security assistance
as well as additional funding for
cooperation on missile defense
and I'm proud that President Biden
reaffirmed his support for for the
memorandum of understanding and last
year's historic Jerusalem declaration
in that declaration again reaffirmed the
U.S commitment to Israel's security
you can also see our commitment in the
Juniper Oak exercise in January between
centcom and the IDF
about 6400 U.S troops participated
in this year's Juniper Oak alongside
more than 1500 Israeli troops
and the exercise integrated U.S and
Israeli Fifth Fifth Generation fighter
assets
and included live fire exercise a live
fire exercise with more than 140
aircraft
it was highly ambitious
and highly successful
and Juniper Oak underscored the depth of
our security partnership
it was a key step in key step forward in
interoperability
helping us both to better address
Regional threats
it showed our ability to swiftly flow in
forces and respond to crisis even while
maintaining our commitments in other key
theaters
now as you'd expect
and you heard the minister say much of
our discussion today
focused on the threats posed by Iran
Iran Remains the primary driver of
instability in the region
and we remain deeply concerned by Iran's
support for terrorism
its dangerous proxies
its nuclear advances
its aggression at sea
it's cyber threats and its proliferation
of attack drones in advanced
Conventional Weapons
now we continue to believe that
diplomacy
is the best way to prevent Iran from
getting a nuclear weapon
but as President Biden has repeatedly
made clear
the United States will not allow Iran to
acquire a nuclear weapon
now Iran's destabilizing actions
are not just a threat to Israel
they are a challenge to the region
and to the world
we're especially concerned by Iran's
growing strategic partnership with
Russia
including using Iranian drones to
terrorize and kill innocent civilians in
Ukraine
and over the past year Russia's military
cooperation with Iran has deepened
and that poses serious challenges for
this region and for the safety of your
citizens
Iran is gaining important Battlefield
expertise
and experience
in Ukraine that will eventually transfer
to its dangerous proxies in the Middle
East
in return for Iranian support in Ukraine
Russia has been offering Iran
unprecedented defense cooperation
including on missiles and air defense
and all that just reminds us of the
stakes
as Russia's cruel and unprovoked War of
choice enters its second year
now Israel has been providing helpful
humanitarian support for Ukraine
and I'm great also grateful for Israel's
participation in the Ukraine defense
contact group that I convene
yet we're also calling on all of our
allies and partners to step up now
at this hinge moment in history
nations of Goodwill and especially our
fellow democracy
Must ALL urgently do their part to help
Ukraine fight for its freedom
and we must all come together to resist
Putin's Grim vision
of a world where autocrats get to decide
which countries can be snuffed out
so we'll continue to stand up for our
interests
our principles
and our friends
and the minister and I discuss ways to
deepen our cooperation with Israel and
our other partners in the region
and we look forward to continuing to
integrate Israel into the Region's
security architecture
you know as a former sitcom Commander
I am especially proud that Israel has
now been rightfully shifted to
the centcom area of responsibility
that change in the historic Abraham
Accords have opened the door to even
greater Regional security cooperation
that means new opportunities to share
early warning and to integrate air
defense capabilities
and to expand Maritime domain awareness
and that's going to help expand
security and prosperity for people
across the Middle East
now we're meeting today
in a time of tension
so we had a very Frank and candid
discussion among friends
about the need to de-escalate to lower
tensions and to restore a calm
especially
before the holidays of Passover and
Ramadan
as we always have we're calling on the
Palestinian leadership to combat
terrorism
and to resume security cooperation
and to condemn incitement
and as I always have I was very clear
about Israel's right to defend itself
against terrorism
I extend my deepest condolences to the
families
of Israelis who were killed and wounded
during recent terrorist attacks
and I am here as a friend who is deeply
committed to the security of the state
of Israel
but the United States also remains
firmly opposed to any acts that could
trigger more insecurity
including settlement expansion and
inflammatory rhetoric
and we're especially disturbed by
Violence by settlers against
Palestinians
so we'll continue to oppose actions that
could push a two-state solution further
Out Of Reach
and we'll work to build on the February
26th agreement in Jordan
including the commitment by the parties
to de-escalate on the ground and to
prevent further violence and to fully
implement the terms of the Aqaba
communique
so we had a big agenda today
we had a highly constructive discussion
and you have I'm grateful for the chance
to further deepen our security
cooperation
again our commitment to Israel's
security is not negotiable
and I look forward to continuing to work
together to make Israel even more secure
over the Long Haul
so thanks again for your friendship and
thanks to everyone for being here and
with that I believe we'll take some
questions thank you very much sir thank
you
we'll start with Yona Bob Jerusalem Post
[Music]
optimism
down played the 84 uranium enrichment
issue he said you know maybe it was in
the state how dangerous
how dangerous do you think the 84
enrichment issue was since it's so close
to the 90 weaponized and uh urinary
management level and how decisive should
that be regarding Israeli and American
policy in Iran not just this week but in
the coming months thank you
uh thanks for the question
you know this is yet another example
of Iran's dangerous nuclear advances
and of course I am deeply concerned
President Biden's preference is to
explore all diplomatic Avenues to ensure
that we constrain Iran's progress uh in
this in this in the in this field
uh and so we would look to continue at
work to make sure that we constrain
their dangerous advances my job as
Secretary of Defense as you know is to
provide the president options if he so
desires thanks
we'll take a question from Idris Ali
Reuters
Mr secretary
um uh the current Israeli government is
the most far right it's been in its
history one of its ministers called for
a Palestinian Palestinian Village to be
wiped out and that was during the Aqaba
meetings do you feel comfortable working
with and trusting a government that has
individuals who have these beliefs and
secondly some reservists in the Israeli
military have
um said they will boycott training
unless prime minister Netanyahu changes
his position on judicial reform are you
concerned about the Readiness of the
Israeli military and what it might mean
for any potential action against Iran
and Mr Minister
um critics have said that a number of
Ukrainian lives could have been saved if
Israel provided military weapons did
secretary Austin make any specific asks
from you in those terms and what will it
take for Israel to provide military aid
even if it's defensive in nature
uh thanks Idris I I uh at the top here
let's just let me say that I defer to uh
my colleague here to comment on the
Readiness of of the Israeli forces
but in terms of our uh ability to work
together
and you've heard me say a number of
times in various places that our
commitment to the security of Israel is
Ironclad
they have been great Partners throughout
and they will continue to be great
Partners going forward
and our commitment to the security of
Israel will not waver it will not change
it is not negotiable as I said earlier
so
well as I said before and I mentioned we
have to be ready
for every course of action all the
options on the table one thing have to
be made clear loud and clear
Israel will not allow Iran to possess
Weapons of Mass destructions
nuclear weapons aiming Israel
as to the
second questions
we are doing our best efforts in
coordination with the United States
to help the Ukraine government to
protect its people and we are doing it
under the understanding of what are the
Israeli interests in the region
times
thank you secretary Austin are you
concerned that the ongoing violence in
the West Bank
distracts from U.S and Israel's efforts
to cooperate on confronting Iran and uh
Minister go on is Israel sharing
intelligence with the U.S about Iranian
weapons that are being used in Ukraine
and um on the iaea's finding about
enriched uranium to 84 percent what do
you think that means for the length of
the window you have to take action to
stop Iran from passing the nuclear
threshold
thanks Alicia as I said earlier I remain
concerned about
what we're seeing in terms of the
escalation of violence and I did discuss
those concerns with uh with my
colleagues
uh
and we're
urging everyone
to de-escalate uh in terms of activities
in the in the West Bank
our Focus remains on working with Israel
and the Palestinians and other Regional
Partners to de-escalate and restore calm
um
our relationship with Israel remains
enduring in Ironclad and so again
there's work to be done and uh and we
had some great discussions on a number
of issues today so
thank you as to the first question let
me put it this way while Israel is
searching looking for its enemies we
find some others and as to what is
transfer in between us and our great
friends in the United States
this is an issue that I have to consult
with the United States before announcing
it
as to the as to the second question
I think that it was said loud and clear
that
Israel will not allow Iran to possess
nuclear weapons while saying at the same
time that their means is to destroy the
state of Israel I am the son of
Holocaust Survivors I'm not I'm not
going
to betray my
loyalty to this
chain of generation
this is a demand to stay strong and to
secure the future of the Jewish people
thank you thank you very much
that's it that's it thank you very much
everyone
okay